hello so yeah hi I'm Chris and I am lead
data engineer for the applied data
science and machine learning team within
a Sainsbury's and Sainsbury's for those
of you who don't know is one of the
biggest supermarkets in the UK and it's
part of my day-to-day role I take the
work that my data science colleagues do
and I translate that into production
systems and what I mean by production
systems are systems which the business
relies on to function so to give you an
example is Sainsbury's does home
deliveries and it's part of that we have
at least three algorithms that
contribute we have algorithms that tell
us how best to put things onto the
shelves we have algorithms which tell us
how best to get those things back off
the shelves and into the right orders
and we have an algorithm which optimizes
the number of vans and drivers that we
should put into our work force based on
a series of business constraints and you
can see from those examples that if any
of those don't work then Sainsbury's
will not function as optimally as it
should and we could start to lose money
so when creating these systems we have
to make sure they're consistent and work
every time and we do that using
test-driven development and it's worth
at this point mentioning that I didn't
start out my journey as an engineer
doing test-driven development when I
first started out I was taught how to
write test plans and test plans are the
really fun exercise of writing a list of
things such as when I click this button
this thing will go into my basket
and I had to mainly go through and take
that off the list and I also worked in
businesses there where the thing that I
was working on was consider of such low
value to the business they didn't want
us to invest time in tests they just
willing it out the door
and then as I matured as an engineer
mainly I thought that Tesla and
development meant completing my work
finishing the code I'd written and then
introducing tests after the fact and
that's incredibly tedious so it only
changed for me when I joined the BBC and
I started working on BBC iPlayer which
is another UK only service that provides
BBC video and for me we I was part of
moving this to the cloud and as part of
doing that we had to build it as a
production system and we were on call I
was one of two people that were on call
for the system and that meant that when
it went down
we had to explain what had gone wrong
and when we first did it we just wanted
to prove a point and we wanted to get
into the cloud as quickly as possible so
we just threw the code up there and when
it went down we couldn't explain why and
you know this is meant to be the future
of BBC TV so when it went down the
entire business was on very alert and
what that meant is that we had to very
quickly change our approach and we
introduced test row and development here
because it meant that we would make our
code much much better tested but also
improved code quality as we went along
and I think the main thing that really
motivates me to continue using tester
and development today is that I was
called out for this before I left the
BBC at half past two in the morning for
a security incident and the BBC takes
security instance very seriously and
being as the I am NOT a morning person
I also took this incident very seriously
so what I realized is that it wasn't
even our code that had broken the
iPlayer website it was another part of
the organisation
who hadn't followed these practices
hadn't really tested the code at all and
put into production which meant that I
had to be woken up a half past two so
when I was a initially taught TV it was
quite a tedious exercise and now the way
I do it slightly different in science so
to help motivate that and return back to
the world of data science
I took an example notebook and the
reason I use an example notebook is
because it's something that I can share
with you because some of the scenes with
algorithms are sort of intellectual
property and it's also very
representative of how we might come to
something in Sainsbury's because we do a
lot of proof-of-concept work and again
that work is to prove a point because
the business isn't mature and as many
large organizations they're not maturing
knowing what data science can do for
them so we often create notebooks to
prove these things out which will then
be put in a queue when we have data
available we have more interest from
stakeholders and then it'll come back
round to us and in the case of this
notebook this particular book is a
pretty good example of roughly the state
that we get code in because it's
relatively clean you know we tidied it
up we put it on the shelf and we come
back to it so the first start of any
data journey is with the data itself so
in this data set you can see on the left
is a series of Pokemon which are indexed
by their unique identifier and they have
a series of attributes about them
whether it be types battle statistics
which attack defense speed and then they
have some information about when they
appeared which generation they appeared
in and also whether the legendary which
is just whether they're a little bit
rarer than other Pokemon
so the second date frame is just picking
though these Pokemon against each other
so in the first row Pokemon two six six
fights Pokemon two nine eight using
those unique identifiers and Pokemon two
nine eight wins and the purpose of this
pipeline is to see whether we can
predict those outcomes on unseen data so
quite a classic data science problem so
how do we typically go about doing this
in don't books we check it as we go
along and this is the kind of typical
scenario that I definitely do in my
notebooks just to look at the data and
inspect it and make sure the
transformations we've done make sense
and this is fairly typical of any
exploratory work and this is the point
where we shouldn't include tests because
we want the freedom to play around and
wrangle the data they explore it in its
entirety so I think at this point it's a
good time to clarify exactly what I mean
by test-driven development and sort of
show how it's like it's more of an
automated form of doing this exact thing
so test your own development in its
simplest form is writing the smallest
test that you can that shows that
something fails and I've got an example
test which just tests the right columns
appear based on the Pokemon we saw the
combats we saw and then collective CSV
file of what I expect to see and clearly
this fails because the function itself
is just passing which means it returns
nothing and this is good for a number of
reasons by doing this process first you
know your test fails and that means that
you can rely on when the test passes
that you've actually implemented what
you wanted to implement and one of the
things that I've seen a lot
we do after the fact s it's not only
ugly tedious and boring but then someone
can come along and delete a lot of codes
and even though we've got 100% test
coverage then that the tests will still
pass and that's because they didn't
check the test would actually fail first
so once we got a failing test the next
step is to make it pass and in this case
to make it pass quickly and easily I
just copied the code from the notebook
because and sort of it's very easy to be
sort of a purist and figure out the sort
of intricacies are bullying us up step
by step but we've done this in the
notebook we've done that exploration so
we can just take some example code throw
it in and make it pass and once we've
done this and we've got some passing
tests this is the great reward of making
test pass is that we're then allowed to
go back and refactor it and what
refractory means is just to go through
and make it cleaner and nicer and if we
don't ever have the safety net of a
passing test then it's really difficult
to refactor because we have these huge
huge functions that we put together and
we're not really sure what parts of it
are useful and if we don't make the test
fail first then we're not even sure or
confident that our tests will cover
error factoring and you can save this
step so usually the process looks more
like red green red green red green red
green and then a bit of refactoring at
the end because you can look the
software architecture as it grows and
this is one of the things that's not
entirely clear when you see that red
green refactor loop so let's head back
to our notebook and that's how I look at
breaking it down and as I say I'm going
to write the smallest possible test
to make this pass and in this case the
smallest possible test for an entire
notebook is quite large so I started
writing it and realized that I had to
implement this extract features function
and this is where sort of the
sensibilities of writing code come in
and I realized that maybe I should have
a look at this feature pipeline first to
see whether I could test the entire
thing as part of this larger pipeline
test so this is the top of the feature
transformation section of the notebook
and as you can see it's quite a lot and
there's more to it further down but
we're gonna stick with this part of it
for the majority of the talk and if we
look at it we recognize that this is
quite a large chunk to test in itself
and this is the test driving and sort of
making you figure out the smallest
possible chunk as you go down and this
is very similar to what we did when we
built I play because we wrote tests that
said hey I would like a home page and
then we'd write an inner test we said
hey I would quite like to have a row on
that home page and then you write in a
test we said hey I'd quite like to have
like an individual item in that row and
we drill down until the sensible size of
a test based on our knowledge and
expertise and this is where you know the
test your own development isn't this
rigorous practice of having to write
tests for everything it's about breaking
down problems and latent test drive so I
created this test which shows a
different approach to creating some
sample data which is using data frame go
ahead on the combats so I'm only looking
at five rows now because that was enough
to sort of create a test to wrap around
the whole thing and I ran that through
the method in the notebook and sort of
took out and the results and stored that
as a CSV to make sure that
my version of it was reflective of the
version was in the notebook and again
because we got all that stuff that we
did in the notebook we can do these
quick and easy tests and generate that
drill down but as I said this is quite a
meaty function to test entirely and we
could just test it with running the
whole thing but sensibly we can break it
down and to do this I just because I've
approached this notebooks I usually
approach my work in Sainsbury's I might
not have as much context as I need to do
this right the first time around so I'm
just gonna have a go and also it's worth
noting the if you've put something on
the shelf for six months and the
business suddenly comes and asks for it
then even the people who worked on it
originally might not quite remember so I
went down and I sort of highlighted this
first bit and I said this adds extra
columns which all the other functions
also add extra columns but for me you
know the next one had some lander
functions and then there was some more
transformations so I thought let's start
by breaking it down this way going line
by line and what that looked like in
terms of dragging out that data was
literally doing this and creating that
CSV file by running the function and
sort of stealing the output halfway
through and again it's just a quick and
easy way to create test data and once I
stolen this CSV file from the middle of
the function then I can ensure that the
exact same output is coming from what we
already analyzed and worked on in that
notebook so when do they were tests like
this which again I pass in combats and
Pokemon
I get back out that expected take the
frame at the bottom and you can see it's
doing exactly what it says on the tin
this is combat as we saw it last time
and here are some additional columns so
as promised
it does actually add columns and as I
said I just copied it from the notebook
so again taking this top section and
then the next thing is that I looked at
the next set of lines and broke those
down and I have these type advantage
columns that I need to do some
transformations on so again same process
red green red green going around and at
this point I'm not really refracted much
because I just wanted to bother for the
set of tests that were fairly
representative and as I say sometimes
you can save that refactoring until the
software architecture sort reveals
itself rather than designing up front so
I end up with tests like this and what
these tests do is show some interesting
things that I did to steal the CSV files
so first of all in this example the
entry point for this function uses the
pre process data from that previous
function that is already saved as a
fixture so storing out and reusing those
fixtures is really important especially
if you're going to do pipeline testing
you can stitch them together across
multiple stages in the pipeline and make
sure that they feed into each other
effectively and then the other one is
that I realized with the wind columns
that this didn't really represent the
dataset very well with only five rows
from that head so I did it with a
thousand instead and again it's just
quick and easy but because it advocated
across the data frame it made a lot more
sense and then finally the most
important part is that I had all these
little functions they looked a bit like
this and this is the fun bit for me with
test-driven development is that because
I've broken it down I now have a very
simple function
which has a very small lines of code so
account and each function individually
describes what it does but as with a lot
of testing it didn't quite pass and the
reason for that is because I've been
avoiding some of the code in the
notebook but this is a really good
example of where test your own
development saved me because of using
that data that I chiefly took from the
notebook because now I can tell that
it's not doing the exact same thing and
I have a test that will confirm that for
me so the example notebook had this
amazing piece of code which removes the
columns down to just those ones that are
important and I didn't really like this
code because I think that I can do do
this in the individual functions and
what I did is I went back to our goods
feature pipeline and using my knowledge
that I've just got from breaking it down
once I can break it down again so the
bit that I thought was additional
columns I could actually look at in
isolation and realize there was just a
few bits there were to do with the
attack on the Pokemon and I could look
my type advantage I realized that you
had a friend at the top of the function
which I've missed in my first go-around
and then also this letter here was to do
with some stuff way down in the function
but I hadn't connected them together yet
so by going through this iterative
reanalysis I managed to break it down in
a different way which allowed me to
focus on getting the right columns out
and this is one of the things that I can
now do because I have a complete test
suite that's green as I can go back and
I can change one function in isolation
and slowly using those example data sets
go back and change the behavior of one
thing in isolation without breaking
anything else and that's
power of a really good test suite and by
going through these things I ended up
with code that looked like this which I
sort of show the similar example at the
beginning where the data frames now
don't bleed out
they just constructed within the
function and then all the
transformations do is add the smallest
possible count out of that function and
I show this example for one particular
reason is that it has these little
helper functions and I didn't write any
tests for these because that's tedious
and I didn't want to because they
represent the logic of this wider
function and this is one of the things
that sort of when your talk rigorous TV
you probably have to write tests for
these things even though they're
one-liners very simple but I believe in
just testing the business logic and
testing the data so these were left as a
testy buy side effect and then what we
ended up with these data frames that I
had originally shrank down to really
easily manageable data frames that I
could inspect in a notebook or in Excel
or wherever I happen to be looking at it
and that was reuse 'fl as well to
diagnose exactly what was going through
this pipeline and then the amazing part
about this is that once I've done that
second round iterating and going through
tests the tests passed and this is the
best bit for me is when a series of
smaller tests actually add up and do
what they're supposed to do because this
means that I did recreate exactly what
my dear science colleagues passed across
to me and our code in production is now
broken down tested and fairly
deterministic so that was a big win but
I was missing a fairly large chunk
of this pipeline and at this point I
kind of written quite a lot of code and
usually when we're doing transfer of
knowledge we pair as a date scientist
and an engineer because they'll
understand it a lot more than I well to
start off with in this case for this
example I wrote this test for my partner
so I just went into the notebook and it
said the accuracy is 96% so I wrote a
test that said it should be higher than
95 because that seems reasonable and if
I change the model at all that would
probably be a pretty good value to go
for and this is a good example of where
in a sort of random ish environment you
can set a load of parameters for your
model and you can ensure that you hit
all those targets that you've predefined
whether it be precision recall f1 score
or anything else
unfortunately my partner is a very
seasoned software engineer and knows
this game very well so she decided that
instead of implementing the model she
would play the tester and development
game which is to write the smallest
amount of code possible and it turns out
for this model it's a little bit less
code should just return the fixture the
it is to actually implement the model
and I think this is a good example of
how like test-driven development can
become a really fun game and how I use
it a lot in my team because you can
introduce this idea of someone else
writing the codes and they don't have to
necessarily get it right but they you
can just build up their knowledge and
understanding as you go which is a fun
teaching tool but if you're pairing it
also becomes a game of ping pong because
my partner then did this and said hey if
you want your model to output those
predictions that you got from that
notebook then you should probably test
that your model outputs those
predictions that you got from that
notebook and
in this case I could have been like mean
I could have returned the predictions
but for the sake of this talk I'm going
to opt to instead just implement it
because this game we can go down into
multiple cycles for a long long time
because we could have hired all those
tests for precision for recall for
anything else you wanted to force that
particular model to emerge which is
quite fun and in a production
environment I encourage this heavily
like actually going back with and
forwards it can take seconds to go
through each iteration at that point but
the importance for this talk is to look
at this particular model with the things
that we had to do to make it
deterministic so one of the things here
is taking from the notebook and fixing
the random state because if it's you
know a random forest then it will sort
of change its value slightly and depend
on where it starts so then the
predictions would change each time and
the we wanted them to definitely
definitely be this model so in that case
what we create is this snapshot of an
output of one particular model and
what's good about this is that you can
actually use that to look at changes in
your model over time because if you
updates SK learn and you run these tests
again you might get a different model
even though it's the same stuff and I'll
give you an example of how that has
changed and you can use that snapshot to
tell you all about what the new
characteristics are of that model and in
a world where we talk a lot about
reproducibility and explain ability this
is very important to us so just as we
near the end of this I want to talk
about the final journey to production
and I mentioned sort of the more pure
formal test drone development you know I
got taught as a software engineer
and one of the things we encounter in
production is definitely bad data and a
lot of the time that comes in the way of
empty data frames so if you're taught
this rigorously you'll start with an 80
data frame but it's just important to be
aware of it when you're pointing systems
in production and then the second thing
is that in production we have bad data
and I don't think that comes with any
surprise but the way we dealt with data
issues and bugs in general is the
because we have that example again we
take it we run it through and then we
make sure that whatever we get out the
other side isn't broken and then we can
use test run development to allow us to
ensure that we fix the bug because we
can see that failing from the bug
straight away in our red phase so sort
of as a quick closing summary TV
shouldn't be really burdensome
especially in data science where we've
done so much work in our notebooks up
front we can use it as a way to teach
and collaborate with others and also
it's a really useful production tool to
help you get code that's clean and
easily readable so I know what's going
on in production but also if you get a
bug it can be really helpful and just
allowing you the framework to track it
down so thank you for sitting through
this talk and here's some QR codes that
can hopefully reward you a little bit
for that but also there's a picture be
looking very triumphant because one of
my personal goals is to come out and do
more public speaking like this and
Sainsbury's has given me the sort of
freedom and the resources to allow me to
come here and talk to you so thank you
so very much
yeah
[Applause]